you
all right let's maybe another Kings
Indian I'm not Grunfeld I'm not a
grünfeld player maybe maybe in certain
lines I would play that okay you know
what I don't have to worry about now the
same ish struck the F pawn so that's
nice
that's always a bit of a bug to me mm
okay I am okay with allowing this trio
of pawns
c4d 44 I'll play this in a bullet game
from earlier
you
okay let's stop e5 and sure enough we do
have that structure all right let's get
the pin in right now while I can if I
don't do it right away there might be h3
and this is the natural follow-up this
is the main idea dark square strategy
going on right now on my side looking to
play against the d4 square the weakest
Square currently in White's position of
the third and fourth ranked squares this
guy here's the one who's sticking out
like a sore thumb no Hahn's around again
to defend that Square unless pawns
capture so I'm looking to do stuff like
this
let's castle yeah we did have this in
the bull game I'm forgetting how that
played out exactly but it's getting a 5
a 5 there's a on d5 a five-night a 6 to
c5 f5 the centers closed with d5 and
that's pretty much the correct direction
of going to at least stake claim to a
space advantage okay not going with that
sometimes you just take care unprovoked
so I imagine taking right away is good I
could get the dark square bishop soph
the board if I want but what about
knight c6
yeah this should be good night see six
so this is the this is one of the
problems what's happening now is that
I'm getting a night to that d4 square
because of how I treated those last
couple moves as mentioned sometimes on
h3 well sometimes regardless of the h3
move regardless of my bishop being
questioned you would just take the
knight voluntarily so and on 92 in this
current position there's a knight takes
Bishop Bishop takes pawn takes Knight
here
I could play d3 yeah
and on a queen takes pawn here I could
take this pawn I'm gonna have good
squares and without the beep on my
knight on c5 becomes a beast and a half
okay they're not taking so I might be
able to just nail the knight right in
there after c5 takes takes and then c5
again
I think I like that idea it's also just
f5
take care
what about a five
ix c5 what's something
mmm
I like this let's nail that night right
in on d5 he's going nowhere and if he is
going anywhere I'm now gonna have a
connected past pawn so you could get rid
of the knight but you'll have to help me
out in that I'd have a connected past
deep on which looking much more
long-term can be of course quite good in
an endgame Ian Punnett and game
all right centers closed time to play in
the wings let's get rolling I'd really
like to trade dark-squared bishop
this bishop is a very bad man very bad I
don't want to allow him to trade himself
off for any of my pieces
maybe there's no rush bishop here to
here was my first thought what about
Queen h4 with Bishop here
I like this better though you know what
I don't like night here though
let's just make one baby move just baby
step it just for a moment because this
is a sensitive point for me one must
realize d6
so this idea Knight b5 what am i doing
okay they're prepping this let's do that
than here see I don't believe that they
can avoid this exchange
Bishop here pawn push it's weakening
I'll see if they weak in their position
and recapture
if you don't take if you don't take here
bishop here maybe
ooh definitely taking on pond takes I
take here my night conveniently defends
this so I don't think I have any worries
of my queen side now
and I don't need to Pete two ponds here
defending my night anymore
okay I think I double up rook here I
want to keep the tension between my F
pawn and their epon let's I'm gonna be
completely committed to this side of the
board
Queen exchange I feel like I could be
playing for an attack here so I'm not
gonna be so quick to trade Queens
actually as much as I usually love to do
that I'm looking for an attack
ooh okay well that pond is certainly
vulnerable let's drop back you can't go
too fat too far away now I have night
moves let's do this keep open the
possibility for a pond push here oh now
this is really opening up and I'm gonna
recapture the pond not just open this
but to defend ie for Bishop there I need
to start moving a little bit faster let
me do this first
just be able to take with the pond like
this and now definitely coming over here
my knight defends this pawn Knight here
threatens Queen takes pawn which is a
killer
Queen takes pawn is a giant giant threat
and here double rooks and that should be
game over night here right away okay
let's get rid of that tempo against the
Queen yeah this is a killer now these
dark squares I was just able to
infiltrate now that's a queen
all right they resigned Gigi that turned
out to be a darks that I referenced it
at dark-squared strategy that was um it
turned out to be successful so I'm gonna
try to offer some advice it's it's
difficult because normally I lean on
okay you know I have the the computer
has my back it'll be able to correct in
any nonsense that I suggest but I think
a ch3 is not the the correct way to go
here and how do you have to be quite
timely and this moment here is critical
already because of the squares in the
center and me being able to camp out on
d4 so one wrong slip with h3 in response
to this move and I think black is
already
equal if not better or it's at least
easier to play now for sure because I
get into c6 I get into d4 and it's very
very very difficult to work around a
knight in your position like this
so mmm what would be better is what I'm
watching you have played at what should
white play here instead of age 3 should
be d5 don't give me this opportunity to
jump into d4 and now I need to go in the
direction like this and here's how you
could play as white as a follow up you
could play Knight here there's night
here and here I didn't mean to do that
let me go back so instead of h3 it
should be this and on this which I'm
trying for this stuff there's night here
and here and of the two I like this one
better so that the knight could
eventually reposition on this square and
this is really good have the knight on
d4 and so let's let's see why that is
the case like here takes takes Knight
here
Knight here look at what he's doing
pressure here facilitates maybe a break
with c5 and this is this is a direction
Y could be trying to go in on f5 there's
this to keep the center and you need to
just be a little bit cautious about the
pawn moves over here not wanting to you
know let's just throw it know a couple
moves in here what do i do as a follow
up maybe this but you want to be a
little bit careful of maybe me clamping
down on a b3 move but this is the slow
slow and effective approach as on the
white side on Bishop here trying similar
there you could do b3 a 3 B 4
notice this Knight again his fantastic
post all these forward squares all quite
influential you could even be um you can
think of more you could have a more
aggressive mentality maybe at some point
by having your knight on this square
with let's say striking
on f4 although I don't know how wise
that is to open up this diagonal but
nevertheless the knight on d3 is very
very influential than it would be on e -
if we compare that with this knight
retreat offering bad bishop for good
bishop exchange he's not going to be as
influential so yeah instead of again
instead of h3 here d5 a five-night here
chop chop
I hear night here and this is your idea
- oops a 3 and B 4 sometimes you have to
do B 3 a 3 and then B 4 but you're
getting these breaks in you're getting
in B 4 you're getting in C 5 and it's
it's another game where white maintains
an advantage here in that of space in
some cases having the better Bishop on
the white side so it becomes tough now
for the rest of the game you're having
to work around a piece or a pawn on that
square it's a no way around it I'm
working with a knight on that Square or
working with the connected past pawn if
you're taking I'm taking and I'm
reinforcing very soon thereafter I
didn't mention this but if you're taking
well I did during the game on takes
takes Knight here I have this move and
on Queen takes there's Bishop takes pawn
and I was very very significant pawn he
is because now my knight gets here and
is there to stay there's no b4 move
anymore
and he'll conveniently defend against
that so some attempt at trying to win
the pawn in other words after my night
arrives here is not working
hunted c5 5 h ra 6 fish up there I want
to get the dark square Bishop sin as
soon as this happened I mean we could do
this little jockeying back and forth
here with the bishops bouncing back and
forth
you know Bishop here Bishop here oops
what am I trying to say yeah Bishop
there Bishop there if Bishop here in the
game you went straight for b4 if this
what I do here cuz I wouldn't want to
repeat I could think about now closing
it up you know cuz he has to go one of
these two if here it's gonna be a
similar similar death I think this is
really really fast and this knight an
animal he is an animal you know I kept
too difficult dark square bishop soft
board last point really is just keep
this tension no reason to declare the
pawns intentions just yet there's no
fear of this pawn playing here you're
having to deal with in a night landing
on e5 takes 95 playing against the
bishop is the main point here don't
allow this Bishop to exchange himself
off I want to keep the Queen's on the
board and this is probably game over as
soon as that pawn played up I was
thinking that white needed to do like
this and still kind of pester me with
these Queen trades if that happened I
think at the end of the day I might have
said I think I might have retreated
right now and then
tried something similar like this and
then
and then maybe like h5 and then boom
boom boom something really quick but as
soon as the dark square bishop suave as
soon as this move was in it's a really
really tough okay GG I've spoken enough
about this one
you